[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
c'est parti stéphane plaza génial
[Applaudissements]
stéphane encore vu les choses en grand
il va arriver ce match de ping pong du
talent il a quoi y'a rasé sa raquette
non non non non non c'est non patron qui
me donne des sous pour eux alors non non
on voit chaque avec l'arrêt braquet
c'est quoi ça c'est quoi cette mc moss a
triché
ah non mais qui rend la sortie à tf1
tournez la dernière fois oui mais non la
trêve et permanent parce que si je perds
apparemment dublin avec l'une des trois
pendant quatre jours avant qu'un jeunot
quinze jours voilà je vais le perdre ce
match
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est en quatre points d'accord les
chéris si je perds j'arrête l'émission
pendant huit ans ils ont des panneaux
l'essaïon didot oui c'est pas 4 pour la
tension ou la vache mais bon il joue son
petit chouchou grave
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
105 x 105 x 4
bonne tout mon coeur kroll strayaway
elle ajouté
et
le 22 mars la piscine non non elle est
tranquille on y va voila voila je vois
t'as pas une petite maison à me
conseiller
on se concentre au lamache petite maison
et à la
[Applaudissements]
défonce le
on adore c'est pas toi
des poches on y va
vim
[Applaudissements]
bakou
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]